there's an intricate brocade fabric
that's been made on giant looms in China
for nearly 2,000 years the inking show
was free media that you got Zuzu she
wants to get good wanna pay oh my god I
see one landing the green Jabbar this
scraping story was made possible by
Nanjing tourism there are a few who know
how to create this traditional fabric
but this man is known as the country's
past llegando ga-ga-ga fella telugu
vaishali enough want a gap and really
what larger foods work for Sergio yet
your son is your father
Yuri gentle father young Chui tada
yo yo pacer the union is thicker than
the average fabric but that's not what
sets it apart each piece takes an
extraordinary amount of time and
patience it is really a great motivation
for missions an amazing achievement in
today no shoes at our parish be inserted
here unless we can the traditional woven
rectangle the team once completed a
piece nearly 8 feet long young whistles
I wanna fall off slowly and they're back
again a few yards can cost upwards of
1,000 u.s. dollars as it is often made
with luxury materials like silk gold and
even peacock feathers to create its
intricate designs
[Music]
using that [ __ ] [ __ ] - I didn't phone
with you without your appliances the
pollution
gurgle and has really true Oh Guido
while Union is no longer created for
royalty the traditional craft is
preserved by those who cherish its
beauty and cultural importance like the
English are leaning Julia yes somebody's
going to sue Jerry winter Eliza she want
to serve wobbly Opry - to the
[Music]
you
[Music]